so for people who don't know this video
is by
a girl who calls herself superwoman on
youtube has i think
five million plays at the time of
recording this
and it's called a geography class for
racist people um let's
let's set it up if you're gonna be
racist at least do it right and look at
this comment under my youtube video
go back to your country you terrorist
[ __ ]
afghan indian muslim [ __ ]
[Music]
notice something this entire video
this is important is is predicated on a
youtube comment
without an avatar or any likes we got a
hint of irony she included that it says
zero no not even one not even two two
would be plus two from zero with all
kinds of misspellings so you know it's
like some thirteen yeah
it could be as it could be a sock
account that was created just for this
here's the important part that comment
obviously indefensible but
she uses that comment as a springboard
to make gross generalizations about
anyone who is republican conservative
right wing that's why it's important to
know that's the setup let's move on
hello
today we're going to be taking a trip
around the world
so you'll need to pack it's probably
been years since you've had the chance
to use your passport
just like your penis but don't worry
this time you'll actually take
off see this is why old media resisted
youtube for so long
um they would say and this is and i
tried to fight against it we've tried to
elevate quality here by actually
spending hours and hours trying to write
material and jokes and source stories
here's a broad who's made it because of
a niche okay
uh she's made it because of a niche
she's an indian in toronto
uh it's a big market there this is a bad
joke that wouldn't even pass at an open
mic
it's it's it's that bad people look at
it and they say llc youtube's nothing
but a bunch of hacks because of this
kind of material but here's the thing
her jokes are not nearly as bad as her
points
or ideas and we'll get to those india is
all the way over here
across the ocean so unfortunately you
won't be able to drive your trailer
there once you board your flight
settle in it's going to be a long
journey but that's okay
you can take a good rest it must be so
exhausting to walk
right through airport security so many
assumptions
trailer dragging it across that we've
already started
with the generalizations by the way i
actually don't walk straight through
airport security and neither does
anybody jared when we went to ireland
uh but i should because i'm much less
likely to commit a crime
or terrorism certainly on a plane than a
muslim
yes muslims who typically come from
countries and they are brown
so terrorist attacks took place in 92
countries in 2015 these are the numbers
that we have um
we don't have ones from 2017 but they
were heavily concentrated geographically
more than 55 percent of all the attacks
took place in five countries iraq
afghanistan pakistan india and nigeria
and 74
of all the deaths due to terrorist
attacks took place in five countries
iraq afghanistan pakistan nigeria and
syria 450 out of 452
suicide attacks in 2015 alone were by
muslim extremists that's more than
99.899
so racial profiling at tsa you bet
yay math the aircraft you're flying will
probably be a double decker which means
it'll have about 300 to 400 people on
board which is approximately the same
amount of people
at trump's inauguration i don't know
about the exact numbers at the
inauguration i'm more concerned with the
tens of millions of americans who were
actually attending work
that day you know the tens of millions
of americans who
elect presidents please note that we're
not gonna fly through the bermuda
triangle because things mysteriously
disappear there
in fact that's probably where your
education went
i don't think miss super bollywood here
fully grasped the concept
of uh education it's not memory
it's not uh it's not a perishable
skill once educated on an issue you
don't lose it that's how many times have
you heard
right an education is something that you
can always take with you no one can ever
take that away from you short
of a neurodegenerative disease or some
kind of traumatic brain injury
for which right now i am yearning deeply
we're going to fly across the atlantic
ocean around
africa and through this passageway
that's very narrow
just like your mind narrow-minded i know
right
just like my narrow-minded trump waving
sign trailer trash geographically
challenged tsa bucking
uneducated mind only none of those are
true i'm sorry you were saying something
about narrow mindedness
you may recognize some of these
countries we're flying over as places
immigrants come from to steal your jobs
or just the same countries you steal oil
from
firstly miss education uh donut phrase
in a preposition it makes you sound as
amateurish as your jokes i know people
are going to argue with me on that
second
i think you need to educate yourself on
the concept of stealing
hint it's not importing almost 2.9
billion barrels of crude oil for a price
between 30 and 50
per barrel in 2016. that's a lot of
money also i think
if you're talking about stealing oil you
should learn what a war for resources
look like
historically it's typically conquer the
area with resources namely the oil
fields once secured you create a
perimeter around the oil fields kill
anybody who comes near the oil fields
siphon out the natural resource and move
on to the next oil
field you don't pack up and leave like
we did in desert storm just a couple
weeks after fighting
or withdraw from iraq as we did in 2011
to let isis capture the oil fields
seems to me like you need to steal an
education
once we reach our destination you'll
notice that india
pakistan and afghanistan are actually
three separate countries
oh i know this people are going to say
this is trivial this is such a canadian
leftist
pseudo-multiculturalist affectation
right listen i'm from montreal
i don't say moyal in english and it's
not because english people are stupid
it's because i know it is montreal
pakistan afghanistan but then she says
india
they don't necessarily say india you put
the accent to try and
note proper pronunciation but you're
just an idiot plenty of countries have
different names in their native tongue
than we use in english notice countries
like espana deutschland austric
and meyer hungary you've never gotten it
right hungry so don't expect me to get
your name right
when you land and are going through
customs and they ask for your occupation
make sure you say trash can and when
they ask your date of birth
be sure to say 3000 bc you
effin caveman i mean i i i hate to say
someone who i disagree with is just not
funny that's not the argument hopefully
the argument of ideas sure
you can take that here but saying you're
a trash can
you're a caveman i mean this is this not
an example of third grade writing
what i bet your dad's occupation is a
trash can bird
you're not allowed at the cool kid's
table uh by the way you mentioned
cavemen miss educated 3000 bc
uh you're off by nearly about forever
scientists say millions of years ago up
until 7 500 bc that's what came in
started doing long distance trading so
i guess you could say you missed it by
that much and i know what you're
thinking
it probably smells like curry no i was
not this is not
i did not think that india smells like
curry we would never make
a gross generalization about an entire
country disgusting on a stereotype
i would think it smells like human [ __ ]
because people poop in the streets in
india 50
actually poop out in the open in india
so i would never make a stereotype based
on a generalization based on stereotypes
i would make it however based on
verifiable statistics 50
in the streets human you'll notice right
away that india is full of beautiful
sights and culture the only sites i can
think of are the people
in the streets just all over i just once
you see it
it ruins the landscape
look at that look at that wonderful
temple i just i can't get that
that guy's dumping right on the temple
next clip and although there are
approximately 175 million muslims in
india
there are approximately 2 billion in the
whole world
which means if every muslim was a
terrorist you wouldn't stand a god
chance nothing like rooting for the home
team with enthusiasm
so yeah she's right there about two
billion muslims see we mentioned
we mentioned muslims on hopper walks
away there are about two billion muslims
that's true
in uh in the world and only a few
hundred million of which believe in some
form of sharia law death for apostates
abuse of women or support the
destruction not only of israel but the
entire jewish people
as far as not standing a chance um i
actually think uh super woman here has a
good point
if we didn't have a country based on a
system of constitutional law westernized
values and individual freedoms you're
right it would
probably be rough we wouldn't stand a
chance we'd almost look like afghanistan
pakistan
or even india good thing we're not now
that we're here
the good news is your wife can save all
that money she spends at tanning salons
trying to look closer to my complexion
first off that's very racist i mean
people throw the term around
you're literally implying that you are
superior because of your skin color
um maybe we'll pull up the definition at
some point i think i would file that
somewhere under racism
uh but i don't really care and nobody
faked hands to try and look
indian maybe this person tanning mom so
you know what
i in being fair and balanced we report
you to that's one for you superwoman
quick travel tip if you're going to
india they don't kill
cows there so there's no beef but don't
worry
because if you kill anything it'll be
considered mental illness
so you're good some social believe
they're pooping in the streets from just
eating vegetables not buying it firstly
second the only person here with a
mental illness is the one responding to
an entirely fictitious group of walking
talking racist fake tanning human trash
cans because of
one youtube comment with an amateur
anonymous
avatar and no likes i'm sorry did i say
mental illness
i meant [ __ ] if you liked this video
subscribe by clicking the button it's a
circular button now that says subscribe
if not head on over the young turks
that's probably more your speed
although they're coming over your [ __ ]
we know you're here watching
i can smell you from here there's also a
recommended video box playing right up
there you can join the mug club at lydia
with credit.com for daily content so
we're not dependent
here on youtube shank go no go you don't
need to stay here this isn't good for
it's bad for your soul